et puis pour terminer comme chaque
mercredi notre chronique des spectacles
ce soir c'est georges bégoux qu'ils
assurent à lyon georges à vue au palais
d'hiver le groupe de rock starshooter un
groupe qui est l'un des meilleurs
français et qui commence maintenant
avoir une renommée internationale
les starshooter ce sont quatre garçons
vous allez le voir il ne manque pas du
nom de province
on a envie de sortir de l'abri bus et de
la masse pour les gens qui pensent on
passe pour des sauvages mais pour ceux
qui dansent
on ouvre à l'écart jamais personne
quelqu'un quelqu'un à regarder quelqu'un
à qui parler
origine sociale place courante un peu
grise moyenne d'âge 22 ans starshooter
ne cherchait pas ça sonne bien mais ça
ne veut rien dire
leur univers cette cave où depuis
l'enfance il passe des heures et des
heures pour conquérir par la musique une
place à part dans un monde qu'ils
contestent pour cause uniformité
moi je n'aime pas la provocation
gratuite et tout ce qui m'intéresse dans
les chansons qui dans les dessins que je
fais c'est de raconter des histoires
dont qui tourne mal parce que racontait
le bonheur des revues qui font ça toutes
les semaines
aujourd'hui vous avez de l'argent vous
en gagnez ça marche bien et soeurs et
mousse pas un petit peu votre
inspiration
non moi pour moi ça me fait mouche pas
du tout parce que toujours pareil je
regarde les autres c'est les autres qui
me fonds dans lesquels je puise mon
inspiration ou dans mon passé des trucs
comme ça et puis mais c'est un fait que
il faut pas tricher avec ça on peut pas
être rebelle on peut pas crier la
violence la révolution quand on gagne
des millions par mois ça c'est un truc
c'est pas possible et aux gens qui le
font pas je pourrai pas le faire
pour l'instant je peux encore le faire
je le ferai un jour je pourrai pas
peut-être que je démissionnerai
à l'instant
m
à temps
non
le soir
le seul point commun entre vous du
lançon et les autres managers c'est
peut-être la fumée du cigare je suis
manager un peu par accident par goût de
l'aventuré démarrage parce que j'avais
une bonne situation et j'ai tout laissé
tomber pour pau vivre cette aventure et
je me suis trouvée manager parce que
j'étais le plus vieux j'étais le seul à
avoir un carnet de chèques au démarrage
voilà le bistrot c'est pas toujours
aussi chic ici c'est pas toujours les
billards
c'est certainement pas toujours les
mêmes des lieux ni les mêmes têtes mais
c'est toujours le même besoin
fondamental c'est de parler de
rencontrer des gens de voir du monde
parce que heures on est isolé quand même
dans la vie on était seul dans le rouge
mais ici c'est vraiment un endroit chaud
un ventre le rock c'est peut-être aussi
une mode c'est une façon de se démarquer
de s'habiller différemment non la
plupart des chansons tristes sont c'est
pas joli c'est pas galileo spa fourmont
regarde vos créé parce que ça leur fait
un petit peu envie il trouve ça marrant
peut-être pas spécialement joli mais et
on garde quand même parce que ça leur
fait quelque chose à acheter tout d'un
coup je suis rendu leur triste et qui
l'ont rendu bon de provocation ait
toujours voté par jean masson eddie
cochran qui pensaient faire c'est de
faire danser les bouts mais c'est tout
c'est ça qui est important en fait
cette issue vers purpan
m